my god you know I slowly have this
process of realizing that all the things
around me that people had told me we're
just the natural way things were the way
things always would be weren't natural
at all they were things that could be
changed and they were things that more
importantly were wrong and should change
after programming prodigy and internet
activist Aaron Swartz took his own life
in 2013 his death became a symbol of
government overreach to his fans across
the internet Swartz was just 26 and was
charged by the US Justice Department
with wire fraud and violations of the
Computer Fraud and Abuse Act for
illegally downloading millions of
academic research articles the charges
carried a maximum penalty of 1 million
dollars in fines and 35 years in prison
we sat down with filmmaker Brian Knapp
and Berger who's made a new documentary
about Schwartz's life called the
Internet's own boy can you just give us
a just a background about him yeah Aaron
Swartz was a sort of child prodigy you
know his fingers prints are all over the
kind of early internet he sort of took
to programming at a very very young age
and was participating in these sort of
programming working groups that really
kind of facilitated a lot of the the
tools that created the kind of free flow
of information on the on the early
internet so he was instrumental in RSS
he was part of an RSS working group he
was the technical architect of Creative
Commons and he was one of the cofounders
of Reddit all these startups say they're
going to go and like change the world
they've changed the world from the
ground up but Aaron Swartz really did
want to change the world through social
justice causes can you just talk about
that for us one of the things that's so
fascinating about Aaron's story is this
kind of decisive turn he took after they
sold reddit right after reddit was sold
to Conde Nast Aaron Swartz became a very
rich 19 year old and he could have
easily done what most people do in the
Silicon Valley startup world that is
just go do it again instead he makes
this turn towards social organizing
political causes really understanding
that he had a set of skills that he
could put in in in the service of the
public good and he didn't see a reason
if he had those skills that he shouldn't
do that once I realized that there were
real serious problems fundamental
problems that I could do something to
address I didn't see a way that to
forget that and it's a way not to one of
Swartz's biggest successes was killing
the Stop Online Piracy Act in 2012 the
bill would have expanded the powers of
the government to crack down on
copyright infringement by cutting back
access to sites that traded pirated
content but critics like Swartz said
that the way the bill was written would
have
to the censorship of the Internet I
remember watching the SOPA protests
unfold day by day you know over the
course of weeks and just having it go
from from just a few people loud people
kind of beating the drum and trying to
trying to get out the word about how bad
this was to being a massive Internet
blackout
a lot of these people were young people
these are people that grew up on the
Internet they grew up having email
addresses they grew up writing on
Wikipedia they saw their future changing
significantly yeah I think sopes shows
that that this a generation felt very
personal about the Internet that it was
something that they really cared about
and that they didn't want to see change
they wanted to kind of maintain some of
the freedoms of the Internet this is a
historic week in internet politics maybe
American politics the thing that we
heard from people in Washington DC from
first office on Capitol Hill was they
received more emails and more phone
calls on SOPA blackout day than they've
ever received about anything I think
that was an extremely exciting moment
this was the moment when the internet
had grown up politically while Swartz
enjoyed success with the downfall of
SOPA another one of his social causes
brought wrath from the government under
the Computer Fraud and Abuse Act
so what Aaron did was he downloaded 4.7
million academic journal articles from
the online service JSTOR and he used mi
t--'s Network in order to get to them
why he did that we don't know we we
speculate in the film we give a couple
of different possibilities I'm not sure
anybody really knows well he wasn't
gonna sell them I mean this is a very
rich 19 year old he didn't need to sell
them like theirs he doesn't need to sell
these I believe JSTOR I don't know how
much they charge for articles but
something around 50 bucks or so yeah if
you go to the JSTOR oh damn it I mean if
you're good if you go to JSTOR you can
spend a lot of money pretty quickly not
very many articles and these are
articles by the way that would have been
paid for it research that's paid for it
by tax payers or research that was
already in the public domain so there's
a couple of reasons why you can kind of
surmise that he might have been after
these articles the most ludicrous is
that he would sell them I mean we're
talking about the 1860 journal of botany
or something isn't it we're not talking
about something they might have a big
street value right a big big value but
some of the other I think more realistic
you know he wrote a lot about being
upset that taxpayer funded research
wasn't available to everybody
particularly people in the developing
world he saw this as a kind of treasure
resource among the greatest minds of our
time contributing to the greatest
problems of our time that should be open
sports was charged by the US Justice
Department with two counts of wire fraud
and 11 violations of the Computer Fraud
and Abuse Act that carried a maximum
penalty of a million dollars in fines
and thirty five years in prison what do
you think that the Justice Department's
message to Swartz and them hackers like
him what was their message that's a
really good question I mean the
prosecutors told Aaron's father that
they needed they need someone to make an
example out of that they needed the case
for deterrence and if you look at
Aaron's life like I have him just made a
film about him the immediate question is
well what kind of behavior were they
trying to deter what were they trying to
deter you know hacking is a very broad
broad a kind of umbrella term that
encompasses all kinds of different kinds
of activity I honestly the vast majority
of what Aaron was doing seemed to me to
be political organizing so what were
they trying to tear what part of the
behavior that he was engaged in were
they trying to deter I think it's a
really good question it's a question we
don't know the answer to because the
case never went to public trial right we
don't know what what the government's
case would have been in this the title
of the film is the Internet's own boy it
comes from somebody who gave you an
interview in the film and the last the
second part of that statement is the
Internet's own boy and the old world
killed him why'd you include that in the
film well I think that we're in this
period of time in which our lives are
changing very rapidly we know we all
live these kind of massively networked
lives and we have to figure out how to
bring into that those networked lives
these these things that we care about
presumably constitutional rights
human rights those kinds of things and
you know the ability of this free speech
the protections that we have already in
place that protect us from government
searches and things like that we have to
figure out how that works
in this new world but there are still
very entrenched kind of sort of powers
that be that that that may not be ready
for those changes and so I think that
and where those kind of tectonic plates
are grinding is is a really interesting
part of our world right now and I think
that's that's essentially what that
quote means that they that the old world
killed him that that we now live in this
new world a world in which he was
nurtured by these kind of Internet
luminaries but those traditional forces
those traditional kind of entrenched
systems just just aren't up up to the
times that are that are you know he was
on Aaron was on the edge all right he
was a little ahead of everybody else
that's just not a comfortable place to
be
[Music]